America has more deaths from the
coronavirus now than any other nation in
the world more than 22,000 people have
lost their lives more than 12,000 died
in this country last week alone and the
pandemic is also causing many to go
hungry thousands have been forced to
wait for hours in long lines at food
banks all across the country feeding
America the nation's largest network of
food banks reported a 98 percent
increase in demand Janet shamlian is in
East Texas with the challenge of helping
people in rural areas where there are
high poverty rates and long travel
distances good morning it's a time of
unprecedented demand everywhere but the
need may be most critical here in rural
America communities where pantries are
closing because food is scarce and
because the volunteers who staff them
are worried about their own health this
is Donna for long and her husband
Leonard their story of how little food
they have it's hard to hear sometimes we
just don't have it so he'll go one day
without eating so I eat and I'll go day
eating so and you know vice versa that's
right
the couple trading off on who gets a
meal they rely on disability payments
food stamps and a pantry that closed in
March because it could no longer get
food where will you go now for food what
pantry will you utilize there isn't
there isn't one that we can go to Jasper
County Texas had six pantries a few
weeks ago three cans of corn three mixed
vegetables now only three including this
one here on
no sir three pantries to serve a county
of roughly 35,000 we're almost 20% live
in poverty and many just lost their jobs
it's a densely wooded region of almost a
thousand square miles some driving forty
miles to get here you've been running
this pantry more than 30 years have you
ever seen demand like this
no it's doubled everything we're doing
is double double double just about every
week it doubles from one time to the
other pantries in rural areas are
closing experts say because they tend to
be staffed by senior volunteers for
their safety
many of them are unable to come in work
at those pantries and therefore those
pantries are not operational those that
are getting food aren't reaching
everyone in it this is an hour from
Donna and Leonard's house they can't
afford the gas it's humiliating and you
know having to admit that yeah we're
starving and things are tough but we're
not the only ones stories like Donna
furloughs are heartbreaking to hear and
hard to believe and sadly hers is not an
isolated case Janet shamlian reporting
on the deepening economic pain in this
country tied of course to the virus